foreign
thanks for joining me here at Stanford
University I'm with Professor Chelsea
Finn who's with both the computer
science and the electrical engineering
departments Chelsea's Visa research lab
that does continuous work applying
machine learning especially
reinforcement learning to a range of
Robotics applications so I'm really glad
to have you here Chelsea happy to be
here so I know that um before you
settled into working in computer science
and machine learning you actually
considered a lot of career options
ranging from biology to Aerospace to you
know computer science and industrial
engineering so what made you make this
choice
like solving puzzles and solving
problems
and when I arrived at MIT for my
undergraduate I was considering
different engineering majors and what
really drew me first to computer science
was that it gives you a lot of
flexibility in terms of the different
paths that you can do essentially
computer science empowers you to build
lots of different things with software
with code and with that I could
eventually go into biology if I wanted
to I could go into robotics there's all
sorts of really exciting things you can
do with computer science so that landed
me in computer science and then once uh
once I decided on that I I really
enjoyed a lot of the math that goes
behind AI like probability and
statistics and I was also really drawn
to this challenge of how can we build a
computer that can see like humans do
that can perceive things in images and
can take actions in the world
so it was almost as if your choice was
um if you do computer science you could
do you know anything and so that that
makes it I guess what mocking Jesus said
software is using the world and I think
Jensen Huang said AI is eating software
and it feels like when you work in
machine learning you get to poke your
nose in all corners of the world and do
fun things in them absolutely I think
machine learning is a really exciting
place to be and I mentioned that
computer science is very flexible and
opens lots of doors and I think that
machine learning is very similar to that
there's so many different things you can
do with machine learning and so many
different applications I'm really
excited about applications in robotics
but uh there's we've we've seen lots of
different applications in language
processing in biology and in other
fields
so your specialization you know the many
things you do a large fraction of your
work is in robotics and um when you know
people look at popular media or social
media you see these videos of for
example humanoid robots jumping up and
down and doing parkour and making
incredible things
um how should one think about what
robots really can and cannot do today
because there's these amazing demo
videos that looks they can do almost
anything but what what how should one
decide what is actually doable yeah the
videos that we see online from Boston
Dynamics for example of robots doing
backflips or doing parkour of course are
really impressive because they look
really complicated and
you it's it's really easy to in some
ways anthropomorphize the robot and
think that if you saw a person doing
that that would be very impressive and
they would probably be able to do lots
of other really impressive things
and the catch is that in robotics in
those videos and in many impressive
demonstrations of Robotics the robot was
set up for that particular environment
and it was tuned to do well with that
setup and if you change something about
the environment about the setup about
what it's supposed to do then the demo
no longer works it the robot will fall
flat
so the really the big challenge with uh
with robotics is getting robots to
generalize to be able to handle lots of
different scenarios with lots of
different objects with lots of different
environments
and
right now robots can do things in very
controlled environments like in
factories and there are very useful in
factories and what I'm really excited
about and what's really hard in robotics
is giving them the flexibility and
generality that of the skills that
humans can do
hey just to dig a little bit more into
the the specific one-off one environment
thing before going to generosity when
someone sees the Nyx cool robotics demo
how should they think about it or what
the questions they should ask themselves
yeah so I think that the first question
that someone can ask is what will happen
if something changes in the environment
uh what will happen if you move a block
or if you put the robot in a slightly
different position when it starts uh
oftentimes you don't see those kinds of
tests of the system's robustness or
resilience to those variations and if
you do start seeing those those demos
where actually you kind of poke the
robot or you change the environment a
little bit and it still works that's
when I think uh we can be really
impressed cool so a lot of your work has
specifically been on making robots
robots to generalize or apply to lots of
different environments
um just tell me more about that work and
how you approach this problem
so in other areas of machine learning
we've seen
where
we take a very large data set like all
of Wikipedia and you train a neural
network to be able to model the data in
that very large and Broad data set
and in robotics one thing that I'm
excited about is if we can somewhat
replicate that sort of success if we can
collect a similarly diverse data set and
allow robots to learn from that data set
now this is challenging for a couple
reasons uh one is that we don't already
have an existing data set we don't have
Wikipedia for robot motor control there
isn't data lying on the internet of how
exactly to move a robot's fingers to tie
shoes for example uh so we don't have
tons of diverse data already but
fortunately robots in principle should
be able to collect data themselves and
that is an opportunity because it means
that we might be able to collect a large
amount of diverse data
by allowing the robots to collect their
own data but it's also a challenge
because it means that we need to figure
out how to allow robots to collect data
that's useful and diverse and so there's
lots of different things that we explore
in terms of approaching this problem
some is allowing robots to collect their
own data in lots of different
environments some is
showing demonstrations to a robot of how
to perform a task we've also explored a
little bit of how to use data from the
internet like videos of humans to show a
robot how to do a task and incorporating
all these different data sources to
allow robots to
um
but once they've hopefully seen very
diverse data sets like this they might
be able to generalize not just to the
one scenario that they saw in a lab
environment but possibly the real world
in the long term
one of the things we're seeing is um
machine learning reinforcement learning
algorithms are great at playing video
games because you can get you know
essentially infinite data playing a
video game with yourself
um what do you think of the row of
simulation
yeah so we've definitely seen lots of
successes of AI systems doing very well
at video games and simulation is uh
somewhat similar because we can collect
lots of data in simulation as well
one challenge with simulation is that
the
physics in the simulation engine are not
exactly the same as the real world we
know generally the laws of physics but
the friction on a table for example may
not be exactly known or the friction
between the grooves but on a cap and a
water bottle if you try to screw a water
ball modeling that is very difficult and
there are it's prone to errors and then
when you try to train a policy in that
simulator to close a water bottle for
example and then deploy it in the real
world it actually doesn't work because
of those errors in the simulation so I
think it's a promising data source but
because of these inaccuracies and this
challenge of transferring something that
was learned in simulation to the real
world I don't think it's the only
approach that we should bet on I think
that we should try to leverage lots of
real data
and is it I want to be surprising to you
know to to some watching this um why is
it so hard to simulate the real world
it's just the water bottles uh you know
two pieces of plastic and somehow we
can't seem to figure out what's going on
with two pieces of plastic
yeah so I
challenges I mean first is is just
modeling the low-level physics uh a lot
of simulation engines out there they
will model time at a certain
discretization and in reality time is
much more fluid than operating at like
100 Hertz or something like that and to
actually accurately model these things
you may need to actually model at a very
fine time discretization and that gets
very expensive and then your simulator
may actually be slower than actually
running things in the real world and
then it's no longer as you no longer
useful in comparison to collecting data
in the real world and then the second
thing is the real world is super diverse
and so actually creating the content of
all of the kind of objects that you
encounter even in everyday life when
you're eating lunch or when you're kind
of cleaning up a table creating all of
that content is actually a really manual
effort and usually in machine Learning
Systems you want to kind of do away with
the things that require a lot of manual
effort and try to automate and automate
things so that they can be scaled
yeah and in fact in terms of the
diversity of environments today
factories work great in robots where the
environment is relatively controlled
relatively few you know unexpected
things happening on average
um I know some of your work has been
looking to send robots into people's
homes and do things in people's kitchens
that's one of the most uncontrolled
environments in the world so say a bit
more about that yeah absolutely so
I think that the controlled environments
are the ones where we've seen a lot of
success and in the long term I would
love to see robots that could go into
any environment like a home or an office
and be useful to people uh and to do
that we want to actually start
collecting data in those environments uh
often time in robotics research we
collect the data once in a lab
environment and learn based on that data
but that when if we only collect real
data in a lab we're never going to
actually get the robots out into a real
world so we're trying to start data
collection efforts actually putting
robots into the real world so that they
see the diversity of all these different
homes
um rather than
um kind of the narrow data that you see
in a lab
so I want to get you a gut about one one
thing which is um you know you talked
about one thing to get the robot to go
into a brand new home and make a bowl of
cereal right challenge liquids cereal
fridge
um what's your guts about how many
different homes how many different
kitchens a robot will need to see so how
many training examples do you think a
robot will need in order to have you
know a good chance of doing on the N
plus first on the next kitchen
yeah so I think it really depends on how
hard the task is if the task is as
simple as uh like I don't know maybe
pressing a button on the microwave then
I think that uh you may not need quite
as much data for that but I think even
for a new kitchen you probably need
still quite a large number of kitchens
in order to to generalize to a new one
maybe
maybe 20 maybe a hundred uh if it's a
test that's more complex like making a
bowl of cereal it's something that's
super simple to people but it's actually
really hard for robots because there's
lots of different steps involved for
that I think you need more data
um and probably also more kitchens as
well maybe maybe in the thousands and I
also think that even if we had thousands
of kitchens of data or or tens of
thousands
my guess is that the problem still
wouldn't be solved fully
um we've seen applications like
autonomous driving where there's tons of
data and the problem isn't quite yet
solved so I think we also need to try to
go beyond the data distribution and also
allow robots to adapt on the fly in a
new environment well thousands that's
higher than Mica and that's interesting
to see how it plays out
and so on on the theme of um you're
making robots more robust I know a lot
of your research work was also on meta
learning or you know learning how to
learn rather than us telling computer
this is a learning algorithm to how they
get a computer to even get better at
learning can you say a bit about that
yeah absolutely so
part of the motivation is that if if a
robot encounters a new kitchen we don't
want it to just
run what it learned in that new kitchen
it may actually need to adapt and learn
on the fly it may need to for example if
it's trying to open the door to a pantry
and the door is a little bit different
it may need to take a little bit of
experience in trial and error on that
door in order to figure out how to open
it and we don't we want to allow systems
to do this sort of learning process on
the fly at test time in New scenarios
and unfortunately
if you just run machine learning from
scratch at test time on a very small
amount of data that won't work very well
you need large amounts of data in order
to learn something so what meta learning
tries to do is it tries to take
experience in previous kitchens or
previous tasks and optimize for the
ability to learn new things the ability
to learn new things based on Having
learned lots of previous things yeah so
for example you know what's the best
learning rate which which to adapt to
new kitchen setting and lots of other
things one could tune yeah absolutely so
the simplest setting is if you're only
optimizing for one parameter like the
learning rate in a new situation and in
more complex metal learning algorithms
you can sort of optimize for the entire
learning algorithm so I think it is one
of the world experts in method learning
in fact if I remember this is a big part
of your PhD thesis which you did way
back with Peter appeal who was my PhD
student at Stanford and so just say more
about how meta Learning Works
yeah so there's a few different
approaches to metal learning but the
approach that was in my PhD thesis was
essentially
putting a learning problem inside
another learning problem so it's
actually forms this bi-level
optimization this two-level learning
problem where you are actually trying to
optimize for all of the parameters in
this inner learning problem such that
you can achieve faster learning or more
efficient learning yep I I remember
reading some early papers and very
impressive um
so lots of uh you know software
algorithms machine learning algorithms
reinforcement learning algorithms one
part of your work is you also run a
robotics lab with robots running around
robot arms entrees for someone that you
know has not yet spent a lot of time in
a robotics lab can you tell us what is
like if a student were to join your lab
what's it like to show up at work in the
morning and work in a robotics lab
lab it's not all that different from
running machine learning experiments
where you run code you try to train a
model and then evaluate that model but
the in addition to to those everyday
things uh there's also interfacing with
the real robot so
oftentimes a lot of projects might start
with a simulation and start iterating on
algorithms using a physics engine that
might involve actually kind of Designing
aspects of the simulation to test the
hypotheses you want to test and
also sometimes projects won't involve
that simulation step or maybe you've
already iterated in simulation and on
the real robot there is everything from
setting up the control stack such that
you can actually command the robot to
move to a certain position to setting up
the cameras to collecting data with the
robot that data might be you might be
collecting data by using like a VR
controller for example to tell the robot
to move to certain positions and then
also actually when it comes time to
evaluate a model it involves actually
running that on the robot and seeing
what the robot does in real life it's a
pretty fun process at least for me I
think it's very rewarding to actually
see the robot do something rather than
just see some numbers or some accuracy
of your model uh but it's also requires
a little bit of persistence because
robots can break down you might have a
motor that breaks you might uh
may not have set up the camera correctly
it might be giving you all zeros for
example there's all sorts of there's
many more bugs that can come up than in
a system without a robot so uh you know
number of people have had experience
debugging software and then there's
debugging machine learning algorithms
which has different practices and ideas
and then can you say a bit about what
debugging Hardware in a robotics lab is
like
definitely so I think that the
I mean in general with debugging you
want to rule out possible sources of
Errors possible sources of bugs and
often times you might have a guess that
is from the software or the hardware
uh and from there I think that I mean I
think that many of the machine learning
things will apply you want to look at
your data and because a lot of the data
is actually collected in the lab it may
not be from a data set then there may be
something that is wrong about it and you
may want to actually look at the images
that the robot is seeing maybe visualize
some of the features that your model has
learned
um
you can also I guess one thing that we
did recently is we wanted to actually
deploy policy on multiple different
robots and so we would actually replay
actions on a robot and make sure that
the robot was
reproducing a certain motion that we
wanted it to reproduce
um
so I guess it's I don't know if it's
really I couldn't get how you debug
depends a lot on the problem I don't
know if there's any one way or any kind
of single bug that comes up the most
because there's all sorts of sources of
bugs
um but yeah that gives us a little bit
of a sense for what it looks like
and I thought one of the lovely and
frustrating things about robotics as
opposed to software is in software if
you make a mistake you can always revert
back to an early version of the software
but that time that you do something and
your robot breaks and then you go boy
that's another two months of work or
something to rebuild that that's a
that's a unique experience in Hardware
definitely and because we're doing a lot
of work on the software side of things
we typically try to get robots that
won't break uh by a very like nice
high-end robot so that we can worry more
about the software and less about the
hardware
um but in there are if there are cases
where a robot might break we try to get
robots where you can pretty easily swap
out Parts where if one motor breaks you
could just swap in a new motor rather
than having to repurpose the whole thing
but certainly there's lots of challenges
that come up no yeah yeah yeah and you
know I used to fly it on those
helicopters so every time a helicopter
crash fortunately we managed to keep it
safe and you know away from people then
there's a this is a frankly destroy
helicopter I think we have to just go
build a new one but it's nice when you
go to do that too often yeah
unfortunately arms Do Not Crash too much
yes maybe I should have chosen working
on that instead
so in your robotics Lab One tool of
choice that you've often used is
reinforcement learning
um
can you say a bit about the your
practical lessons tips and tricks for
how to apply reinforcement learning
amazing algorithms to to your Hardware
robots yeah so reinforcement learning is
a really
for robotics
would allow a robot to
think completely on its own through
trial and error from data that it
collected itself uh and so it's
something that we're really excited
about for that reason but it's also
really challenging for a number of
reasons so first reinforcement learning
typically assumes that you're given some
reward signal some feedback and if
you're trying to learn how to play a
game like like play a pong or an Atari
game another Atari game uh you can just
use the score as a reward function and
just try to maximize your score but the
real world doesn't give you a score uh
it doesn't give the robot a score when
it tries to learn something and instead
the robot might need to learn its own
reward function it might need to learn
what it means to accomplish a task at
the same time as also trying to learn
how to accomplish that task in the
physical world so that's one big
Challenge and and one way that we
approach it
another challenge is typically in this
trial and error and and so how do you
learn the reward like from a
demonstration how how do you learn the
reward yeah so we we learned it in a few
different ways we often give it at least
give it some examples of what success
looks like uh and we also sometimes give
it a full demonstration of this is an
example of what we want you to do and
then you can get into techniques like
inverse reinforcement learning which
you've worked on a long time ago as well
and actually try to kind of invert the
reinforcement learning process and try
to figure out what reward function
underlies this Behavior so beyond
learning reward functions another
challenge is autonomy in the process of
reinforcement learning so typically you
think of it as a trial and error process
where you try try to solve the task and
then you then want to kind of try it
again and in between trying the task and
trying again
you need to somehow get back to some
starting point
and uh maybe for example if you're
trying to learn how to back how to do a
backflip uh trying again will involve
standing up after you fall down
but actually sometimes learning that
resetting Behavior is also quite
challenging and there's this challenging
interplay between learning how to do the
task and also learning how to recover
from all the ways that you failed at the
task
um in the entire process of doing that
it's really automating the research
process that lets you run repeated
experiments without having to you know
lug a robot around every single time to
put it back exactly yeah cool very cool
and in fact in your application of
reinforcement learning
um I think you are one of the earliest
researchers you're among the earliest
researchers to do you know more or less
or completely end-to-end robotics
um end-to-end reinforcement learning can
you can you say a bit about what that
was like in the early days and why you
went that route yeah so at the start of
my PhD deep learning was just starting
to become popular after Alex net was
showing that you can do very well with
deep neural networks trained to end to
end for computer vision
and I had just arrived at Berkeley for
my PhD and there were some people that
were working on reinforcement learning
with neural networks and I was pretty
excited about that work and I wanted to
see um in the past work it was all blind
the robot wasn't using cameras in any
way and I wanted to see if we could
learn a neural network that directly
maps from the images taken by the
robot's camera to the Torx applied to
the robot's joints and in that first
project it was a lot of work to try to
actually get that initial result but we
were excited to see that we actually
could get a single neural network that
could learn something like screwing a
cap on a bottle or putting a coat hanger
on a coat rack uh with a single neural
network mapping directly from pixels to
torques and it was a pretty exciting
result I
it was definitely very different from
what the rest of the robotics Community
was working on uh and I think the paper
that we we worked on was actually
rejected twice because people didn't
like deep learning they didn't like
roboticists didn't like that these
neural networks were very black box and
you couldn't understand them but
eventually got published and was
accepted uh
and
um now it's it's actually become a much
more prominent Paradigm in robotics
where a lot more people are now trading
neural networks to represent the policy
to represent how the robot chooses
actions based on the camera images
I think that early work you did was
quite Visionary and set an important you
know hope said important New Direction
for the field what's your prediction for
where this will go do you think the
percentage of practical robotics work
that is trained end to end how much do
you think that will continue to go up or
or not or
yeah I certainly think that it will
grow
still not all of the robotics research
Community is looking at these kinds of
approaches in part because there are
useful techniques in control theory
um that are useful especially in
controlled scenarios like we talked
about
but I think that it will certainly grow
I think that especially with as the
machine learning field continues to make
really impressive advances uh I hope
that that will convince more people that
this sort of Paradigm is really
promising for robotics as well
especially in terms of handling the vast
um degree of variety in objects and
environments in the world in terms of
looking forward in terms of like
understanding what might happen in the
next uh 10 or 20 years in robotics uh
one thing that I'm really excited about
that we touched on a little bit is
trying to train robots on broader data
sets a lot of the field of robot
learning is still collecting a data set
for a project in a lab and then training
on that small data set it's small
because it has to be because you
collected it for that project
and I think if we imagine that uh if
computer vision researchers had to
collect imagenet for every single uh
project that they did they probably
wouldn't be making that much progress
and so I think that my prediction at
least for um for the coming years is to
move towards a paradigm where we reuse
data sets a lot we use much larger data
sets and ideally are kind of sharing
data sets across institutions across
robot platforms
um and scaling up the data that these
systems are trained on such that they
can generalize more broadly
that's an exciting vision and how do we
get there for images everyone uses you
know PNG files and GIF files and JPEG
files so the data is highly postponed
highly shareable
um if different research Labs just have
different pieces of Hardware how how do
you make that happen for robotics
excited about is first
um trying to actually have a little bit
of consensus bring the community
together to say okay let's start with
this robot platform with this roughly
this setup
um so that we can at least standardize
on some of it and then try to collect
lots and lots of diverse data on that
fairly standardized platform uh start
from there and then if we're able to get
some signs of life and some positive uh
success from collecting a broad data set
with those standardized choices then
starting to standardize less and less
and move not maybe the same robot but
with a different control stack and then
maybe starting to move towards different
versions of that robot different
grippers and and ultimately lots of
different robots and lots of
environments cool no right this is
exciting vision
and in fact um
so this is one of the things you're
doing in robotics
um just looking more broadly
you know with all the workers union
reinforcement learning some not even
apply to robotics but to other other
applications what where where do you
hope reinforcement learning and Robotics
will go in the next many years
yeah so I think that the I mean I'm
hoping that it will move towards these
reusable data sets and very broad data
sets
um
I also think that even Beyond
um robotics I think that there's lots of
other applications of reinforcement
learning as well so for example in some
of our recent work we applied
reinforcement learning and actually meta
reinforcement learning a combination of
metal learning and reinforcement
learning to education to give feedback
on student work where students would
program a game like breakout and then
the system would actually play the game
and find the bugs that the students made
and give them feedback on how to improve
their program and how to continue to
learn how to code is very cool in fact
um robots are so visual sometimes it's
easy to forget that reinforcement
learning is a general technique for
decision making with delayed rewards
um that's useful for many things other
than robots too
like uh frankly I I want to see more
robots where I used to I I used to try
to get all my patients to learn to
solder I don't know if that was a
I learned how to solder in undergrad
although I don't think I actually ever
used that in my robotics work oh wow I
see oh
maybe things have moved on but I had to
yeah you see yeah I think we would just
buy robots that didn't need some
soldering so your journey has led you to
do cutting-edge work in reinforcement
learning and Robotics
um I'm curious what advice you would
have for someone looking to break into
reinforcement learning or to robotics
not everyone you know owns a cool robot
that's an easy program but how should
someone get started
yeah my main advice would just be to try
to get your feet wet and uh just try to
build something try to uh program and
and code something up there's lots of
different things that you can do and I
think that learning by trying to build
something by trying to do something is
uh one of the coolest ways to learn
because you have a certain goal in mind
but would you build something using a
simulator robot or do you think you
should just you know build a little
robot
I think that starting with a simulated
robot is probably the easiest and
there's there's less of a learning curve
and less uh
less things that you have to do you
don't have to go out and buy Hardware
that said I think that also uh trying to
work a little bit with Hardware right
off the bat is is great and there's it
it definitely teaches you about uh how
hard robotics is robotics is really hard
uh but also
um by kind of struggling to get the
robot to do something it makes it all
that much more rewarding when it
actually does something cool when it
does something that you want it to do
and uh I don't know some of the robots
that we use are are fairly expensive but
um nowadays there's actually lots of
robots that are fairly inexpensive uh
that that people can buy or you can kind
of build your own robot by connecting
wheels and and a camera or maybe even a
smartphone together to build something I
actually got started with Lego robotics
in middle school and you can also build
robots out of Legos and get started that
way yeah Yes actually I remember I
remember I went to Lego robotics
competitions when I was in middle school
or something that was that was
interesting Southern experiences so to
to someone you know taking the machine
learning specialization uh
if the goal is to work in reinforcement
learning and Robotics what else would
you recommend they look at what are the
other resources you think would be
helpful
totally so there are resources in terms
of like just learning about
reinforcement learning uh and there are
kind of courses online there's
um for not there's also kind of course
videos there's textbooks like Sutton
Bartow
uh and so those are lots of resources I
also think that there are lots of I
don't know videos online tutorials code
bases you can actually check out a
physics engine like the majoco physics
engine which is freely available and try
to kind of explore with that
um so yeah those are those are a few
resources there's also
um one thing that we use a lot to
interface with robots is called the
Robot Operating System or Ross and so
learning about that can also uh be
useful that came out of my research lab
way back working with a weather garage
yeah
yeah so I think that those are some of
the resources and yeah not not too much
more than that cool yeah very cool it
feels like you know with the world
moving forward and evolving feels like
the number of paths for someone wanting
to get involved in this is is even
growing and this probably gets a little
bit easier every year for someone to
enter this view so there's an exciting
time to be in yeah definitely thanks for
joining me here at Stanford University
I'm with Professor Chelsea Finn who's
with both the computer science and the
electrical engineering departments and
leads a research group that does
cutting-edge work on applying
reinforcement learning and machine
learning to Robotics and other
applications thanks for joining us
Chelsea yeah happy to be here